c'est du jamais vu en plein mois d'août
barcelone est littéralement déserte
avant la pandémie la ville recevait
habituellement 16 millions de visiteurs
par an notamment concentrés sur les mois
d'été
mais aujourd'hui les touristes se font
rares un grand nombre de bars
restaurants et commerces sont encore
fermés d'autres accusent une baisse
importante de leur chiffre d'affaires
du côté des hôtels seuls 20 % d'entre
eux ont rouvert leurs portes avec un
taux d'occupation allant de 10 à 15%
alors beaucoup d'établissements du
tourisme étranger et s'inquiètent donc
d'une fermeture définitive si la crise
sanitaire se poursuit et pour cause
l'activité touristique est à l'arrêt à
barcelone et dans le reste de l'espagne
depuis mars et l'espagne fait donc très
cher sa dépendance au tourisme qui
contribuent habituellement à 12 pourtant
de sa richesse son pib a baissé de 18 5%
au second trimestre il s'agit de la plus
forte récession d'europe et de la plus
importante du pays depuis la guerre
civile
c'est donc historique entre avril et
juin il ya même en millions d'emplois
qui ont été détruits
alors aujourd'hui tous les espoirs
reposent sur le fond européen de 140
milliards d'euros dont va bénéficier
l'espagne pour relancer l'économie